we're going to show I'm very happy to be
joined by Albert and Jason from triple7
Studios creators of the il-2 Sturmovik
series I guess the latest of all we're
going to play right now battle of
stalingrad I'm also happy to be joined
by mr. drew Scanlon from Giant Bomb
how are you Aang very happy to have you
here because although I have played many
flight Sims on my day I know drew as a
well you're the head of the flight club
on giantbomb so yeah I'm an airplane
nerd yeah at a world war two nerd as
well sure yeah so delighted have you
here to help me ask these gentlemen
questions about this game so yeah tell
us first of all when is that I has this
been in beta for a while I feel like
I've been seeing a lot about bamboo
Stalingrad yeah early access now and we
close to to better you open early access
about one year ago and we already have
players so people play buying so
everything ok cool nor the game alright
also we just let's just jump into
straight away okay at the first about us
who we are
something or special happened to us
because I just bought the game and 2002
okay so Sturmovik and became part of
community and who I am now the producer
of the holes here oh really
yeah this is some kind of dream come
true so everything has been kind of like
at the top of World War 2 flight
simulator you like a best party I like a
decade right the most complex and the
most biggest Kyle a scale game about a
world war 2 aviation of course yeah so
we are proud to present you may be the
most experienced and talented team and
in this genre in all market about the
game so three things we want to say or
for everybody like first or flight sim
is a game about the challenge like we
developing games to provide you
opportunity to develop yourself like
level up level knob not just to to
killing thirty minutes in your life but
to learn something you the second things
but the flexibility like in this game we
try to create something easily to start
with like simple joysticks
you don't need to super setup for
beginning and you can start flying I
guess that's the problem with flight
Sims yeah is that yeah there seems to be
a big barrier to entry
yes everybody everybody this is this is
not true like everybody thinking that
this is too complicated for me I don't
want to just like this is not true it's
enough a simple joystick lies about 50
bucks to start and of course after these
you can level up level up and in the air
I'm the part of the Big Society of the
people who really love aviation history
and this type of game and the last
things emotions like yes we provide
emotions if if you feeling yourself
flying under the Stalingrad in 1942 just
for 10 seconds we do everything ok
because this is there a unique
experience you you cannot find this in
other games yeah this is very special
what's important to flight semi is to is
to give the user a sensation of flight
like they're really in the aircraft and
in the case of Stalingrad you want them
to feel like they're in the war so the
certain level of immersion that you want
to give the user and we think that with
what we've done here we've accomplished
that it's not yeah is it is it unique
for a flight sim game to be centering
over I guess a relatively small piece of
land considering like most flights in
games power a lot of them span over like
different campaigns in different parts
of the world whereas although Stalingrad
was probably the most pivotal point on
the eastern front it's it's quite a
dense piece of land for a flight sim if
you guys had to like put extra detail
into that absolutely and you'll see from
the video that the guys have modeled a
very large portion of the Stalingrad
front in battle it's actually the
largest most detailed map ever put into
a PC game of the Stalingrad theater a
game like we were talking earlier about
like Red Orchestra where you actually
fight in Stalingrad that's just one a
couple city blocks and we have hundreds
of miles of surrounding landscape where
the actual tank battles and and aerial
dogfights and bombing missions took
place and along with like a hundred
different airfields that you can fly out
of so it's an immense project in a
beautiful map I can just demonstrate it
yeah the top the top straight into it if
anybody familiar with a radar cursor
game you can easily read
nice the territory so this is the bottle
map I'm showing from build oh yeah and
this is the stunning rod and I want I
just want to show you the scale so it's
of course it's not easy to create game
in this scale but possible so if you
playing Red Orchestra you you must know
this level calling training station so
yeah the German spawn point at the left
and the Soviet spawn point at the right
and this is the whole level like inna
flight sim this is just a little special
little piece of the map so I can fly
these higher higher and higher to
understand what we're really doing so
this is the huge map creating with a lot
of research and information because also
one interesting things happen in Russia
we right now have Declassified archives
from Warwick - okay and we can rub a lot
of new information about the technical
elements about the bottle itself so
right now we can tell you a completely
new story about everything and of course
sir laughs and attention to details like
this is this is a really detailed model
of every aircraft in the game like from
from the cockpit or from external view
and a lot of little things like you are
nice
just open cockpit yeah the engine idling
is is buffeting the cockpit but not the
wings all right yeah these little things
that make er we try to create a special
visual style like the modern visual
style this is not only the game about
clicking buttons and know everything
about how to start the the airplane but
this is also game about visuals like to
say about the feelings about emotions
you're flying under the bottle
Stalingrad in 1942 so to that end what
part of the story do you play is there a
campaign that sort of threads you
through a large period of time or
a lot of different things like because
our community not not a solid piece of
people who want this and don't know and
don't want this they they want different
things like the first things are the
world is over Gaming is rapidly changed
so right now nobody have you know five
hours in a day to play again sometimes
you have 30 minutes or just one hour
this is why we're creating the quick
mission like couple of clicks and you
can create the mission you want with
different weather conditions with
different time ground objects click
click start and it's ok 30 minutes of
fun and that's all realism normal yeah
whatever types realism do you have ahh
of not worse we we expect again
different people like we have normal
this means the a I helped you to manage
all this system like supercharges flaps
gears a lot of things but you steel
flying on the real physics and real
aerodynamics and all of these things and
the export players can do everything
manually like of course if you want this
you need to eat a lot of manuals so it's
you've got a couple of them ok yeah yeah
we're talking fuel mix and propeller
pitch pelipper yeah great radio you need
you need to do like 10 operation between
before you can takeoff takeoff yeah in
the normal you just need to press EK or
but but what I mean give me a second
yeah to that end that's actually happen
and then show some gameplay on a second
to explain you about a I was challenged
because this is single-player game we of
course with multiplayer experience but
mostly single-player and we create in
special special AI for the game like
with all these physics we cannot create
simple or simple system like just the
dork like waistline you have Weybridge
now this is a really artificial
intellect the same as the flying drones
right now in the military because the AI
need to fly this plane
so what happened I'm
stopping engine right now ok and press
ek again like stop the engine and look
what happened all of these things start
moving exactly like the pilot I mean
human do this or if you're an expert
mode presumably you would have to get
you in order so this is what I mean say
normal normal I mean for normal people
and export for expert pilots for non
normal people oh yeah you're not normal
no absolutely yeah let's not like we hop
into a mission show actually some of the
flying someone's shooting and stuff like
that because I think that's a ultimately
what a bunch of the folks at home when I
get into you guys also have a
multiplayer I'm assuming in this
dogfighting skirmishing and so yes we do
we have a very robust multiplayer system
with the server browser built in also
users will be able to create their own
missions and host their own servers and
there's lots of virtual squadrons out
there they get together and fly
regularly not only can you do simple
dogfights but also you can team up and
start doing objective based missions on
the mole in the multiplayer world where
one guy flying the bomber and one going
to find the fighter plane and you work
together to accomplish the mission all
right here we're going yeah this is like
just looking from their topic this is
our enemy so we have everything in if we
need
lazy for me a while flying to the
kalksus
yeah yeah nothing that is that it very
special experience yeah and there's some
questions coming from the childís when I
get to as well are there a variable
weather conditions yes and we have a
special generator for this so nobody
know which type of clouds you can expect
in the next mission
you can always say like Tesla clouds or
or overcast and after this system can
generate the clouds layer for you so
every time you need ohayo yanking
GameSpot's asking I will they're
actually bunch people were asking me
this earlier today so will this Lippi
updates to rise a flight or is all
development going into il-2 decisions I
know rights of flights incredibly
operator okay what they're getting at is
is some users on our community are
disappointed who are big world war one
fans rights to see that we have have
potentially stopped development on their
favorite we're we're once have to focus
on Stalingrad of course this is our
latest project so most of our resources
have been going to battle Stalingrad the
future of rise a flight right now we
haven't decided what updates we're going
to work on in the coming months however
we do have an update coming very soon it
will add an additional airplane to the
game later this month also we have also
announced that we're working on another
world war one flight sim product called
Ilya Muromets which is a the product
will feature a large bomber from the
Imperial Russian Air Force and Rover one
and where we're designing and building
that product on conjunction with the
Russian military oh there you go Wow
been there my friend I'm life okay oh so
fun to play flight sim because you
you'll stay safe I drill you yes sir
yeah when you're playing a bunch of you
how many do you play many of the stern
fish games in the past
I played the original 1 1946 yeah a
little bit back in back in the day and
there when you sort of come to a flight
sim now with you know we've got
sort of busy schedule busy lifestyle as
well like how what is it you look for
when you're playing one of these games
is this like your quick like sort of 30
minute campaign or admission or do you
go into larger campaign or honestly it's
it's just for me
flight Sims is all about like mastering
the aircraft so like DCs one of my
favorite series like I haven't even gone
past like learning all the systems mmm
and Rhys a flight is another great
example it's like I just barely learned
how to fly my aircraft but that's
already immediately rewarding so the
fact that you can just hop in here and
get to shooting but like that like
things like propeller pitch and fuel mix
aren't yeah you know put aside is super
easy now what drew hits on is something
that's always difficult in the flight
sim genre because there are the hardcore
guys rivet counters who really care
about the very small details about the
aircraft and the history involved then
there are more casual players who just
want to get in and fight and fly and
dogfight we try to find that balance
between a hardcore physical world where
you can you can get your fix on the
details but also now we're introducing
some more gameplay elements getting back
to the campaign you mentioned will have
there's four different phases and you
have to complete each phase to progress
in the campaign and as you go you'll be
presented with new types of missions and
certain equipment unlocks that are
historically based of course but you
don't necessarily have at the beginning
of your campaign so we're combining both
the hardcore and the game is it's a lot
faster yeah there's this this is evolved
to flight sim like what we want you to
you can fast or put you yourself in a
cockpit and start flying
we've no any obstacles between you and
this experience and soon after this you
realize that how big this world because
this is a I can call it the small like a
facebook war or this is small society
but very very addictive things yeah sure
you start speaking discussing things
learning things more and more and more
and you'll be gamified I guess it's a
bit you guys have a lot of big big
community stuff going on with with your
previous games I'm sure it's going to be
the case with this one as well
and last question for this series
obviously it's coming out pretty soon
you've got is it beta phases coming out
soon are you guys going to continue to
support this game in the future and what
does that involve I guess when you're
sort of you're focusing on a battle
that's quite rigid like styling grad
happened in this time period well lucky
for us world work too involved a lot of
different battles a lot of different
fronts a lot of different theatres a lot
of different airplanes so our hope which
is why we got into doing Sturmovik is
that we hope that this will be the first
of many future products that we get to
develop and this is of course base it on
how much players we can attract right
this idea because you know that they're
hardcore seems it's not easy to produce
so if you can find a audience of course
we have a lot of ideas what we can't do
to to to create this excitement so we
help and working hard of course
flight simulations I always say are one
of the most difficult games to develop
but also enjoy the smallest audience hmm
so it's it's always a fight and we're
one of the few teams left in the world
that can make these kind of games and we
like to think that we're the best at
making these kind of games so the future
looks bright and we hope that our
community and others who may be watching
this broadcast take a look at our
product and give it a go again you don't
need complicated setup mouse keyboard
and a $50 joystick is really gonna doses
cheaper than the ps4 controller I have
to say like I said all you need just a
chance Albin Jason thank you so much
coming on and showing us il-2 Sturmovik
Palestine grad just guy left enjoy month
yeah you bet as well thank you we had to
put a twitch spot which is now rubbing
my leg periodically and much appreciated
week
[Music]